so right now the overwatch League is
getting a lot of negative attention
big-name talent just left viewership is
allegedly inflated and the travel
schedule is intense to say the least but
here's the thing all of these issues
we're talking about have either existed
for a while now or they've been a long
time coming so on December 31st
overwatch caster Monte Cristo posted a
lengthy Twitter thread announcing that
he wouldn't be returning to the
overwatch league for season 3 and then
on Monday January 5th Doha officially
confirmed via Twitter that he also
wouldn't be returning to the overwatch
league for season three and then on
January 1st Chris Puckett also announced
that he'd be leaving his full-time
position with the overwatch League and
transitioning into freelance work it's a
new year I got a new logo and a new
location Molly got a promotion bringing
us back to New York City where we lived
for 11 years and unfortunately that
means I won't be on the west coast to
host the overwatch League for a third
season I had a blast over the first two
years and I know now as a freelancer
it's not the end of the road for me I
hope to be joining everyone in the
overwatch league and the cult Duty
leagues hosting and commentating the
biggest event in front of the people I
love the fans in the community now while
all of this has certainly newsworthy its
Monty's reasoning that I actually find
most interesting in the second of his 12
tweets he wrote the departure of Natan
answer from Al led to irreconcilable
creative and philosophical differences
between myself and the league's current
leadership and all parties will be
better served by parting ways and dhoya
said something pretty similar now a lot
of people in social media saw these
announcements as oh [ __ ] the overwatch
league is screwed if Monte Cristo can't
save us nobody can and like me you
probably saw Monty's tweets and thoughts
yourself oh [ __ ] this is not good for
overwatch and you're right it's not but
in fact the problems go a lot deeper
it's no board
and doomed fail things like burnout and
mental health concerns for example
continue to be a hot topic within the
overwatch community notable players like
effect
Asher D Fran and pine all either retired
or took extended breaks from pro play in
part due to both of these issues and
with home stands right around the corner
with the beginning of season three which
are basically blizzards equivalent of
home and away games even more concerns
have been raised due to the crazy nature
of this travel schedule now you might be
wondering what's this about a crazy
travel schedule well there's a team in
Shanghai there's a team in London
there's a team in Paris and there's a
bunch of teams in the United States
which naturally means people are going
to be traveling a lot and so what do I
mean by a lot well according to a report
from up comer the London Spitfire will
apparently have to travel an estimated
76,000 923 miles during season three and
according to that same report the Boston
uprising will have to travel an
estimated 70 1460 miles as well well not
every single team will be traveling that
much according to that upcoming report
most teams on average will be travelling
about 40,000 miles throughout season
three for comparison the LA Lakers will
have to travel that much this NBA season
so no matter how you look at it being a
pro overwatch player in season three is
gonna be pretty intense now you have to
imagine that these pro overwatch players
and casters since they'll be traveling a
lot as well or asking themselves is this
worth my time and effort when I can
essentially just stream from home and
[ __ ] I don't even want to think about
the potential visa issues that might
come from this but there's a ton of
other issues with the o WL as well there
was that disaster of a merchandising
deal with fanatics where logos were
peeling off hoodies and jerseys were
basically unreadable and then there's
the overwatch contender series which has
been picked apart by Blizzard to the
point where there's almost no more land
tournaments the league is hardly
promoted on stream and teams are folding
left right and center but none of these
issues are more concerning than the
allegations that Blizzard has been
inflating viewership numbers by
embedding overwatch league streams on a
whole gang of websites basically what
allegedly happened was that
websites were paid to run muted owl
streams as ads on their websites during
game days so the idea is is that if you
visited Kotaku polygon or even SB nation
while a game was live you'd be counted
as a viewer even if you didn't intend to
watch that stream now back in May of
2019
Kotaku actually published an
investigation that highlighted some of
these allegations in the piece writer
Cecilia Donna Stasi Oh highlights the
fact that a company called curse were
responsible for these embedded streams
now according to the report curse was
once owned by twitch and in 2018 twitch
paid overwatch 90 million dollars for
the exclusive rights to stream the
overwatch League so suffice it to say
the term conflict of interest comes to
month now obviously lizard denies all of
this and in fact they said that the
season two finals did pretty big numbers
for them at this point it's a bit of a
he-said she-said but the fact that
there's any doubt about the viewership
metrics in a league where you had to pay
tens of millions of dollars to even get
in the door well that's pretty
concerning while all of this is going on
an overwatch in the CBL which is
Activision Blizzard's other fully
franchised League they've actually
pulled back on the crazy travel schedule
and they limited the number of events
that they'll be doing for 2020 to bring
it back to Monty he wrote on Twitter
that I will be suspending production of
oversight with my co-host thorn and will
cease creating overwatch focus analysis
and power rankings on my personal
channel and then he ended that Twitter
thread with although I enjoy making
these videos the low demand for
supplementary owl content means that my
energies are best used elsewhere simply
put Monty's not stopping because he's
not allowed to make our content anymore
he's stopping because the audience
frankly isn't big enough and that even
more than Monty leaving even more than
the crazy travel schedule and even more
than the alleged inflated viewership
numbers is the most concerning aspect of
all of this
the [ __ ] am i doing what am i doing
called alright I sleep wake up every
morning and I'm just like alright let's
[ __ ] fumble through another day you
know yeah